truth can be difficult to Define at  times truth can be nuanced it can be  multifaceted it can be complicated our  willingness to pursue it constitutes a  very onerous Endeavor and our ability to  tolerate truth showcases the strength of  our character granted that we want the  truth why not rather earn truth and  uncertainty even ignorance the problem  of the value of Truth presented itself  before us or was it we who presented  ourselves before the problem the idea of  questioning almost everything is  emblematic of niche's writing style  through this process he recognizes that  one becomes smarter and cultivates a  more holistic understanding of the world  he was sensing that we will be in a  position very soon to understand the  world around us better so it is time to  destroy the old world and lay the  groundwork for the new one